okay good morning everybody we are about
to get started with this press
conference from health canada and the
public health agency of canada my name
is marika walsh i'm with the global mail
and i'll be your moderator today we have
opening comments today from dr supriya
sharma the chief medical advisor at
health canada dr mark bertiom director
of the bureau of medical sciences at
health canada
dr teresa tam the chief public health
officer of canada and dr howard new the
deputy chief public health officer of
canada so we'll take those introductory
remarks now and then we'll turn to
questions over to you doctors
thank you marika uh so good morning good
afternoon thank you for joining us today
i'm here to talk to you about health
canada's authorization of pfizer's pax
levitt
pax levitt is a prescription drug and a
combination of two antiviral drugs
nurmatravir and retinovir for treatment
of mild to moderate covid19 and adults
at high risk of progressing to serious
disease including hospitalization or
death
until now the medications for treating
copin 19 we have authorized have had to
be given intravenously or by injection
in a hospital or a health care setting
this is the first oral covid19 therapy
that can be taken by patients at home
which is an important distinction
the treatment consists of two tablets of
a nematrovir and one tablet of retonavir
taken together
twice per day for five days
the treatment is intended for use after
a diagnosis of covid19 and within five
days of the start of symptoms
diagnosis should be made using a
positive test on an authorized kobit 19
test confirmed by a health care provider
health canada received the submission
for pax levitt from pfizer on december
1st
and conducted an expedited review the
authorization comes at the completion of
the critical review of the data that was
submitted showing that it met health
canada's safety efficacy and quality
data standards
pfizer has been submitting data to
health canada on a rolling basis
throughout the review process with new
information being received as recently
as last week
the recent data also included laboratory
information confirming the effectiveness
of the medication against the omicron
variant
this submission included data from a
clinical trial conducted in unvaccinated
non-hospitalized high-risk adults with
covid19 infection having symptoms
the shetty the study showed that
treatment with paxlivid compared with no
treatment reduced the risk of
hospitalization and death caused by
cobit 19 by 89 percent when the
medications were started within three
days of the beginning of symptoms and by
85 percent when started within five days
health canada's review determined that
the benefits of pax levit outweigh its
potential risks but it's important to
remember that inherently all drugs carry
some risks and this is no different
paxlivit is a prescription medication it
has the potential to interact with a
number of other commonly used drugs in
ways that can decrease drug
effectiveness or in some cases cause
potentially serious effects
as with any prescription medication
patients need to discuss the risks and
benefits of treatment with the
healthcare provider who is aware of
their health conditions and other
medications
following authorization of medication
it's important to continue continue to
monitor both their safety and
effectiveness once they start to be used
in the health care system
health canada has applied terms and
conditions to the authorization of
paxola that require data from ongoing
and planned studies to further
demonstrate the safety efficacy and
quality of the medication
for example there are terms and
conditions that require ongoing animal
studies to support further assessment of
the medication safety for use when
pregnant and breastfeeding women and
monthly poll market safety reports for
the next six months as well as updates
and results from additional studies
and if any new concerns are identified
health canada will take immediate action
and communicate with canadians
the authorization today provides a new
tool in the toolkit against cobit 19 at
a crucial time in the pandemic as we're
faced with new variants
importantly it is a more accessible
antiviral treatment for those at high
risk of progression to severe covet 19.
and while we're here today to talk about
this important new treatment option i
also want to remind everyone of the
continued critical importance of getting
vaccinated
no drug including pax levitt is a
substitute for vaccination
and vaccination along with public health
measures remain the most important tools
in preventing illness from coving 19
infection
both the public health agency of canada
and health canada continue to strongly
recommend vaccination for all eligible
canadians
i know everyone will be interested to
hear when and how pax levitt will be
made available in canada which will be
discussed by colleagues later from the
public health agency of canada thank you
merci linguich
for being with us
this is
and it is
who is aware of their health conditions
and other
monitor both medications safety and
effectiveness once they start to be used
in the healthcare system
canada has applied terms and conditions
to authorization
to the authorization of
that required data from ongoing and
planned studies to
and breastfeeding women and monthly
post-market safety reports
assessments as results
if any new concerns are identified
health canada will take immediate action
and communicate with canadians
is
importance of getting vaccinated no
medications
and public health measures remain the
most important tools in preventing
illness
from public health agency of canada and
health canada continue to strongly
recommend vaccination for all eligible
canadians
thank you
bonjour
hello everyone hello
it's my pleasure to be here with you and
my colleagues dr new doctor sharma and
dr bethyun
throughout this pandemic the government
of canada has taken the responsibility
to procure covet 19 therapeutic products
to ensure that canada has early access
to safe and effective treatments
since the onset of the pandemic several
different types of treatments have been
developed to help reduce the
severity of covid19
covet 19 treatments along with
vaccinations and public health measures
are essential to save lives reduce
illness and lessen the burden on our
health care facilities
and today health canada announced it has
authorized paczlovid the first covet 19
therapy that can be taken at home
the treatment is the combination of two
antiviral drugs nomatrevia and ritonavir
the public health agents of canada works
with public services and procurement
canada to secure access to safe and
effective covin-19 treatments
today's announcement is particularly
important as access to easy-to-use
treatments could help to reduce the
severity of covin-19 in adults who
become newly infected
and are at high risk of progressing to
serious illness
in december the government of canada
signed an agreement with pfizer for an
initial quantity of one million
treatment courses of paxloved
while there is currently limited global
supply on paxlovid we are working to
firm up a delivery schedule
with the intent of bringing treatment
courses to canada as quickly as possible
ministers duklow and tassie will provide
further details on the distribution of
the treatment later this
afternoon province and territories would
determine how best to manage the
available supply with support from the
public health agency of canada
the public health agents of canada met
with provincial and territorial
colleagues to discuss deployment based
on a per capita basis with adjustments
that take into account shipment
requirements from pfizer
to help inform their planning the public
health agency of canada has provided
provinces and territories with interim
implementation considerations for the
deployment of the initial supply of
plaque slovad to treat covert 19 in the
context of supply limitations
these interim recommendations are based
on clinical risk factors and health
equity considerations
first consideration is prioritizing
individuals who are at the highest risk
for severe illness and hospitalizations
individuals in the following categories
have the highest likelihood of severe
illness and should be given priority for
treatment given limited supply
first
those who are moderately to severely
immunocompromise
not expected to mount an adequate
response to saskovic to infection
regardless of vaccine status
secondly individuals over 80 years of
age or over whose vaccinations are not
up to date
and third individuals 60 years of age or
older residing in underserved rural or
remote communities residing in a
long-term care setting are those living
in or from first nations inuit and metis
communities whose vaccinations are not
up to date
our second consideration is to make a
greater supply available for use in
rural and remote communities where there
is limited access to tertiary care and
in situations where social and
economic determinants of health such as
food insecurity inadequate housing and
the higher level of pre-existing medical
conditions may exacerbate health
inequalities
the third consideration is that
infection must be confirmed and
treatment initiated within five days of
symptom onset if pcr testing is not
possible or if results were not
will not be available until more than
five days from symptom onset rapid
antigen tests may be used
drug interactions and access to
alternate
effective covert 19 treatments are also
factors to consider
i would like to provide a reminder that
no drug including pathology is a
substitute for vaccination or public
health measures this is another tool in
the toolkit to fight the pandemic
it is important that everyone gets fully
vaccinated and receive a booster dose as
soon as they are eligible
over time our immune response from
various vaccines decreases
a boosted dose produces more antibodies
along with other immune cells help to
strengthen our immune response to
protect against severe illness
finally canadians are reminded that both
mrna vaccines currently available are
safe and effective and help protect
against severe outcomes from covet 19
therefore they should feel confident in
accepting whichever vaccine is offered
to them
both the public health agency of canada
and health canada continue to strongly
recommend vaccinations for all eligible
canadians including those who are
pregnant may become pregnant or are
breastfeeding as always vaccination
including a booster dose is the best way
to protect yourself your families your
communities against severe outcomes from
covet 19. thank you merci meigridge
bonjour
yeah
the government
is
is
the public health agency of canada with
public services and procurement
has been working together to secure
access to safe and effective coverage
today's announcement is
we are working to firm
bringing treatment up to canada as
quickly as possible
ministers
mr administers duklow and tessier will
provide further details on the
distribution of the treatment later this
afternoon
territorial
the public health agency of canada has
provided provinces and territories with
interim implementation considerations
and territories
is
vaccinations are not today
whose
not
yeah and a higher level of pre-existing
medical conditions
and access to alternate effective 19
treatments
we would like to remind you that no
drugs
it is
more antibodies
along with other immunities immune cells
hope to strengthen our immune response
to protect against
digestion
canadians are reminded that both
accepting whichever vaccine
okay thank you so much doctors as there
are no questions in the room we'll turn
it over to
the telephone lines we have until noon
today for questions and answers so
please keep that in mind so more people
the shorter the question and the answer
the more people can get a question over
to operator
thank you miss you may press star one if
you have a question
the first question is from ryan tommelty
from the national post please go ahead
yeah hi there so i'm wondering uh in
practical terms how you see this drug
being dispensed um i assume that to get
a prescription for someone will need a
um
a positive cova test and there's such a
shortage and delay in those and with the
fact that they have to
get the drug within a few days of
treatment
i wonder if you see a lot of practical
barriers to people actually being able
to use this drug
let's talk to you maybe i could start oh
sorry i uh
okay go ahead dr tam
um sorry about that so i think the
there are definitely operational key
operational considerations on the ground
and provinces as well as the clinical
networks in the system are thinking
through that
right now
and they have been doing so for example
for
the utilization of some of the other
treatments like so trova maps so this is
not starting from scratch they have been
looking at how do you
actually provide these treatments to
those who most need it
and so
i think the pcr testing and testing in
general by the province and territories
have been prioritized to the high risk
groups
so they will likely consider doing that
as well
um
so that that actually aligns with the
prioritization of treatments is that the
testing is being prioritized for higher
risk individuals
but
you're right in that there's many
innovations on the ground that are being
thought about right now and using for
example community pharmacies designated
prescribers
making sure that testing
centers for example can direct people
to the right
clinical expertise
and also setting up um
reference um
expertise
for example um dr sharma and as we've
mentioned the issues
with
drug drug interactions so if you're on
certain medications you have to be
careful
when they're using this drug
and for that the
pharmacists as well as
clinical experts
have been discussing how best to provide
that reference reach back so that
frontline prescribers will know what to
do
it's doctor new maybe i can just add
some additional points to what dr tam
has said
as you can see from our opening remarks
uh the public health agency of canada
has developed a document uh for
considerations by our provinces and
territories in terms of
the deployment of of this this uh this
uh treatment which we uh appreciate was
probably a sort of initial limited
supply and uh certainly i want i want to
give a shout out to the clinical experts
of this ad hoc group we put together
that really gave their their valuable
time and expertise you know they're on
the ground on the front lines and they
they gave us a bit of a reality check in
terms of the practical uh issues that
they'll be facing on the ground in terms
of delivery of health care and so with
their input we develop the
considerations as you can see in the
document which i understand will be uh
posted i think publicly on our website
uh if not a radio
shortly that gives that initial sort of
considerations uh to the provinces and
territories recognizing that you know
the way health care uh delivery set up
in each of the the jurisdictions uh uh
is slightly different then takes into
account as well a
unique uh aspect such as you know uh the
the proportion of you know remote
isolated communities uh social
determinants and so on so with all that
in the mix uh hopefully uh the guidance
we give in terms of considerations that
will be used to get effect by the
provinces and territories as they move
forward with the initial deployment of
this treatment thanks
yeah maybe just as a follow-up i'll ask
this question a bit more directly
as i understand it the way the drug
works someone would have to develop
symptoms
see a doctor get a test
get a prescription get the test results
back
and get the drugs and start the
treatment
all within
five days for it to be most effective
given the current situation in canada do
you think it's likely someone will be
able to do that
dr
tam
yes so as i said that um i think these
drugs um these treatments this first
treatment that is taken orally and can
be taken how will be
in high demand
and there are mechanisms being set up
right now to make sure that individuals
in these high risk groups
for example clinicians looking after
those who are moderately or severely
immunocompromised are getting themselves
ready to
respond to the needs of that group
and those in long-term care and other
places as well so
um i do think that the
criticality at the moment is um really
you know nobody in the world has enough
supply um but i do think implementation
if you recall that right at the start of
the vaccination campaign the initial
doses were relatively small but it gave
us a chance to essentially get all of
the
system rehearsed and
ready for when there's more supply so i
kind of see the initial
doses as being just part of that system
testing itself out and getting itself
ready
yes doctor and you maybe can decide if
you look at the the
the highest risk groups in terms of the
elderly
especially you know in certain settings
uh uh certainly what we appreciate from
the clinical experts who gave us their
their best input and advice uh on the
ground is that
you know that's what is being looked at
within the various provinces and
territories they're already i think
being uh sort of the prioritized or even
testing so if you were a clinician on
the ground uh dealing with patients in
those high-risk groups immunocompromised
elderly and so on uh certainly uh uh if
if someone develops symptoms uh i think
uh you know certainly i can't speak for
the provinces and territories but i
would think that uh those individuals
would be at the sort of close to top of
list that like you know get that rapid
sort of assessment that test uh and
results and then uh hopefully uh you
know be uh be given that the medication
uh as pressure though the way the
province and territories are going to
use uh this treatment
thank you
is
will make a difference if testing is not
accessible considering that you have to
go to the doctor get a test quickly
will it practically be possible to get
this drug
mexico
vaccination program
and other public health measures
uh
actually
what i think is that currently in
provinces and territories
healthcare providers
uh
we can use rapid testing as well if it's
not possible to access a molecular test
thank you for this specification
there are many
when will we feel the difference that
they will bring
say doctor
hear this doctor knew maybe i could call
it
we said
i don't know
from developing severe illnesses
uh
is
vaccination
so this is an additional tool
you merci the next question is from mia
rabson from the canadian press please go
ahead
yeah hi um i'm just wondering going back
to sort of what ryan was asking about we
know for example that it's really hard
to get testing done right now these
priority groups that you're talking
about are supposed to be prioritized for
that but even getting rapid tests can be
difficult so
can we sort of revisit this this this
issue of how easy it's going to be to
actually get this two people within five
days the the practical realities of that
yes teresa tam so
again that has to be worked out on the
ground but it is challenging there is no
doubt about it
first of all spotting that you may have
symptoms and then getting
attention medical attention quickly so i
do think increasing awareness um
to the at-risk populations
that there may be treatments available
now um even though you know we
anticipate at the beginning the supply
is
not going to be great anywhere
but if i think one is public awareness
that if you're in these categories and
do pay attention to the provinces when
they announce who they're going to be uh
supporting initially
um
and then um you know follow the
instructions that are provided because
each community is going to be a little
different in terms of how they're going
to roll this out
as i said there's there's
initiatives on the ground to try and
facilitate the implementation
but there is no doubt that one of the
key challenges uh of these antivirals is
uh to the fact that they have to be
given really
early on in the course of um the the
clinical course so
um not easy
but again we i think everybody really
just needs to give it a good try because
it would be
i think an important tool going forwards
some people have talked about this
before as a so-called game changer in
the treatment of the pandemic obviously
supply issues would have to come up in
order for any real impact but i'm just
wondering if you can talk about what
this really means towards going from
this sort of
intense stage of the pandemic to a more
endemic phase
well i think given
one of the key goals is to reduce the
severity impacts of this pandemic
this
kind of treatment that people can take
at home
and unlike some of the
monoclonal antibodies that has to be
given by several infusions
at a clinic or a
healthcare
setup
this is going to be much easier to do
but the
challenges that you've identified just
now are continually going to be
challenging so
one hopes that
the testing as well as the rapid
deployment um will be worked out in the
coming weeks and months
but they will definitely add
anot another really important tool
because it will blunt
potentially blunt the severity
of the illness which is the key goal
and it also offers those who don't mount
a response to vaccination or couldn't
get vaccinated for whatever reason
who are at the highest risk
of severe outcomes
um
hope as well as
the reduction in the pressure on the
health system
thank you for taking our questions
is there a moment where the symptoms
become too
moderate forms
we
symptoms
i would like to talk on accessibility
again
dr tam was talking about the fact that
rapid tests can be used as well to
confirm an infection in order to get
access to the medication
is that it can you just get a
i don't know if doctor new has
additional comments
we messy
and that's why we included it in our
documents considerations
i'd also like to specify that this is
not a treatment for people who are
already hospitalized
to be used
it's really most beneficial in the early
stages of illness
thank you man the next question is oh
sorry
when i said someone talked to you but uh
uh oh doctor
doctor
comedy and gamma and uh
hospital treatment for those who have
severe illnesses
it's important to use all of the tools
thank you
thank you merci the next question is
from abigail biman from global news
please go ahead
hi thanks for taking my question i just
want to understand a bit more when you
talk about um people who are not
vaccinated being on the priority list
i'm wondering what kind of discussions
there have been around uh you know the
the limit the the limited amount of this
drug and and how expensive it is and and
whether people who choose not to get
vaccinated should be put on a priority
list
yes it's teresa's ham so this is a
scientific and rational use of the drug
that is in short supply we know
that um the unvaccinated at higher risk
of getting severe outcomes and getting
hospitalized and ending up in the icu
so this is the evidence and we're
following that evidence
and
um
so i think that
as healthcare providers you don't pick
and choose which patients you have
coming into the hospital getting treated
and so i think this approach ensures
that we are prioritizing uh treatments
to those most in need
and i
really appreciate the input from the
experts including the ethicists
who
contributed to this discourse
and
the priority groups you have now
represents the collective efforts at
laying down not just the clinical
criteria but the ethical considerations
as well as health equity
thank you and i also want to ask given
there's such a long list of people who
shouldn't take this drug due to being on
other medications or having specific
conditions um that long list seems to
overlap with the population you would
deem to be at highest risk so i'm
wondering sort of in layman's terms if
you can describe how accessible this
drug would be to high-risk populations
like would you say most high-risk people
could take this drug or is it only a
small percentage of those at high risk
to covet how helpful will it be
so um maybe i'll start and i i'm not
sure if dr sharma or others will add yes
according to the product monograph one
of the key
uh considerations
is the interactions with other drugs so
the key is that this is a prescription
medication because
that's one of the key considerations so
i can't tell you percentage-wise exactly
how many of the high-risk groups will be
on that list of drugs uh i don't have
that figure but i do think that it's
absolutely worth
consultation with health providers and
not
be scared to deploy this drug either
the expert pharmacists as well as
physicians
and other health providers will be able
to work this through with the patients
and perhaps just to add um yeah i mean
the way that the medication works is
that there's one part that actually
interrupts the way that the virus
reproduces and that and then there's
another medication that blocks the
breakdown of that
drug and that's the return of your part
and because of that retinovir is there
that's why there are so many drug
interactions but that's not unique to
this this medication so there's a group
of about 27 drugs where we're saying it
should the product should not be used if
somebody is on those drugs and then a
much longer list of products where there
might be some interactions and you're
right that if you have people at higher
risk so if people are in the older age
group or have other illnesses they're
more likely to be on those medications
but that's why we put all the
information out uh on these drugs so
that the pharmacists are aware the
healthcare practitioners are aware and
people are aware of which medications
that they may be on that might might
interact and it might be you know
because it is this is a short course
it's a five-day course it may be that
some of those medications could be
stopped for a short period of time or
there may have to be some dosage changes
so it really is the way that we look at
all medications if there are
considerations on how they should be
prescribed or how they are best to be
used we want to make sure that all that
information is out there so that people
are aware of that and then they can make
their health care decisions
appropriately
thank you merci
and this question
medication need a prescription from a
doctor could a pharmacist write a
prescription uh
so this is a prescription
depending on the problem
[Music]
and there are also some provinces that
have delegations
prescribing
other professionals so everything will
depend on the context but what you need
is
other medications
because it's still only a five-day
course i'll let dr knew jump in if
there's anything else
there is a long list
[Music]
is
many of these problems have a solution
but it does
require clinical pharmacologically
as i said there is a long list of
medications
there is a long list of medication that
is contraindicated
thank you merci the next question is
from dylan robertson from the winnipeg
free press please go ahead
uh hi dr tam is it not inequitable to
distribute this resource on a per capita
basis when we know that certain
provinces and territories have much
higher proportions of immuno compromise
in the royal patients and much lower
hospital capacity
dr tan would you like me to
sure you go ahead and i can supplement
if needed
okay well thank you for the question the
reason i'm jumping is that
sort of uh i i've been started more at
the sort of the programmatic level or
just take a level uh working with our
counterparts in the provinces and
territories so maybe i could just start
with uh sort of the principle of the per
capita allocation was it's a starting
point in terms of uh uh distributing uh
the the treatment uh
obviously courses uh across the country
but
uh it's also been taken to account the
fact that there are certain populations
for example indigenous populations that
uh that are also uh you know uh having
different uh say uh proportions within
the province of territory so that's also
been taken into account uh there's also
been uh for example a certain allocation
given to indigenous services canada
obviously to look at a specific settings
for example remote nursing stations and
so on so that's a part of sort of the
complexity of how we're actually going
to allocate and obviously we'll uh we'll
see as we go along in terms of any
adjustments that need to be made in
terms of demand and need uh with our
problems and territories but as soon as
the starting principle it's just easier
to state that you know we're doing on a
per capita allocation but you know
obviously there's a lot of uh
uh detail and other sort of nuances that
we're working on behind the scenes thank
you
it's marico welcome ottawa we have time
for one more question and a follow-up
um sorry do i get a follow-up too
oh sorry dylan yes
no it's okay um i hope indigenous
services canada provides that number
today um and dr sharma can you please
explain how this is related to the
monoclonal antibody treatment is there
any sort of clinical guidance for when
the antibodies are best versus the pill
or is it solely on a question of
logistics and distribution
all right so i mean all of the
treatments that we have whether they're
for
uh so a lot of the monoclonal antibodies
are really for a subgroup of patients
with covid19 that are actually in
hospital or quite severely ill and
that's once you've had the the illness
it's been established um to to have
those those treatments help to decrease
the severity of illness this is a
medication that because it blocks the
replication of the reproduction of the
virus
that's why you need to catch people
early so these are for people who are
have been exposed to covid19 they have a
part they have some symptoms that have
started they've got a positive test and
it's really to prevent them to progress
to progressing to requiring
hospitalizations or intensive care we
are we do have other long-acting
monoclonal antibodies that we have under
review so one of those products is
edushield and that is used even before
you have any symptoms so basically you
don't know you don't have covid yet and
it's really a long-acting monoclonal for
prevention so you know we also have
other medications that are treating
severe people in hospital we've got the
remdessever that's been authorized
the zotropimab as well and uh other
medications like steroids so you know
that's why it's a basically you know
it's a it's a tool kit that we have of
different therapies it's still best
obviously to prevent
infection overall so getting vaccinated
is still the best prevention in terms of
covid illness
especially severe illness
hospitalization and death we know that
the vaccines even in this omicron wave
are very effective against that but
really there are some groups that
potentially don't have that immune
response
either because they are unvaccinated
under vaccinated or they have an immune
problem or they have other risk factors
so this is really one medication in that
area
to try to prevent hospitalization and
death
thank you merci the last question will
be from travis danrosh from cbc news
please go ahead
thank you uh my question is for dr tam
or dr sharma
rapid antigen tests you said would be a
significant a sufficient diagnostic tool
if no pcr is available now we know
experts have said that these rapid
antigen tests are sometimes unreliable
for a drug where supply will be limited
at least to begin with wouldn't it be
more prudent to only prescribe it to
those that have a positive pcr result
yes the
challenge with this medication is to get
the test done early and i think
the principle that was being
worked out in the
consideration document is that
yes you can try and get the pcr test but
if it's simply not available or not
available fast enough then the rapid
antigen test may be used that's just a
very practical approach
yes rapid antigen tests may have their
limitations
but they are
there in um greater availability in
certain settings so i think use whatever
tool you have on hand but the key is
that given the supply and given the need
for a
prescription and
to direct therapy appropriately
getting that test right now is
considered a imposing consideration
and perhaps to add with respect to the
tests just to respect it that has the
rapid antigen test i think you know some
of the the issues around um how
effective they are really are for what
we call false
sort of negatives basically if you
actually do get a positive test on a
rapid antigen test that is quite
specific
i think the concerns are that they're
not as sensitive as the pcr test so
potentially you know it wouldn't
necessarily pick it up if it's earlier
in that case a pcr test might pick up a
positive earlier than a rapid antigen
test but if you have a positive rapid
antigen test it's actually very accurate
which is why it can be used in terms of
uh the indication for for using pax
levitt
yeah and it's doctor you maybe had a
final point in terms of rapid antigen
that's uh certainly i think uh the
limitations a lot of experts are talking
about is in the context of someone is
asymptomatic or has no symptoms uh at
all and sort of a the kind of other you
know the rate of false results you would
get from that but certainly in the
context of someone who is developing
symptoms uh the actual sort of what we
call a the pretest predictive uh
positive uh you know result is much
higher so uh i would say that certainly
uh you know pcr would be ideal but i
would say that in the context of someone
is symptomatic it certainly is
acceptable to have a rapid antigen test
and would give
a good results in terms of then deciding
whether you need to maybe be eligible
for this treatment or not thanks
thank you and this is a follow-up to dr
tam i'm wondering if you can kind of
zoom out here big picture uh if we look
at this drug over the next couple of
weeks
how much of an impact is it going to
have on this wave that we are dealing
with right now and how much is this a
forward-looking drug
yes um i think a lot of it depends on
the initial supply and we all know that
the supply isn't going to be great at
the start
so for the omicron wave itself it may
contribute but it won't be a key
contributor to
the current wave so it is very much um a
um lay another layer another tool um as
we progress over the next months and
hopefully with other treatments as well
but i think just to end the press
conference to
on a positive note this is great news
overall
um the regulator
as well as the experts helping us with
the guidance and the supply are all
coming together
at once and
i think canadians should be very happy
today to hear that
the oral antivirals are beginning to
become available in canada
okay this ends the press conference with
the doctors the ministers uh duklo and
tassie will be available at 1 30 this
afternoon thank you so much
thank you